Shalom
à Chalom shalom shalom
à ouais est-ce que je suis le seul qui a
qui qui me Réville deux fois par nuit ou
pas ah ben moi c'est à cause de ma
vessie mais ça c'estautre chose ah c'est
la vieillesse moi moi c'est à cause du
froid
non mais s ça ça me manquera pas le
froid oh les amis non non mais on se les
gel ici on c'est pour ça qu' porte des
robes on sait pas ce qu'il porte en
dessous ça d'après moi
j' oublé quand il parlait c'était drôle
pour moi c'était un relou en fait c
devenu un relou remarque tu es le mec le
plus drôle du monde mais tu étais d
relou demain je vais vous expliquer
pourquoi j'ai tout fait ça ah mais c'est
fou vous allevez tout comprendre c'est
c'est ouf et céit un choc quand on a
vraiment pu reprendre la vraie parole
parler d'un coup en fait de retour à à à
la parole du coup à la vie entre
guillemets euh c'était dingue c'était
vraiment
dingue